[Music]
okay thank you it's a talk my name is
understable I work at Warsaw University
of Technology but this is just a little
side project we've also medical
university and I will talk about
childbirth and about little data science
in it okay what is Friedman curve it is
a curve on the x-axis we have time in
hours from the start of the label and on
the y-axis we have dilation and to end
the dilation reaches 10 centimeters boom
baby comes out okay and one way I think
this curve is wrong because this study
was actually done in 1955 and then
average age of the woman giving the
birth was 20 and there were some medical
procedures applied to this woman with
her actually not standard anymore so the
conditions change very much and also
they approach the men who did it called
it something like a graphical
statistical procedure but I think he
just took the points that looked good to
him so okay and I think this is even
dangerous because actually this is very
outdated and not really scientific but
actually the doctors and the win wise
put this curve in the box and this is
bad
but they also even made clinical
decision based on this curve and this is
even worse
like if the woman is progressing too
slowly maybe you should apply some
oxytocin to her or some even
cross-section which are really serious
actions and for me as a woman this is
pretty frightening and probably it
should be - okay so we made little pilot
study about this the peak we have 500 of
women and they were all
human with healthy children and it was
not a hospital but a building center and
actually these five hundreds of women
it's all of the beers from 2015 and 2016
so it's quite a unique opportunity
because we have only physiology like no
medical interventions okay
and what we want to study we want just
to calculate things like how long it
should take for example for the first
stage of the label and we can see that
there is a definite difference between
first-time mother and experienced mother
and I made something like this Freedman
care of myself
okay these red points is this organelle
original curve that I think it's wrong
and these bars
it's our data and okay we want at least
try something like not just single
points but somehow distribution like it
looks for and we have I still have big
difference between first time and
experience matters and as we can see
actually our mothers were quicker than
this gold and all rotten standards of
Freedman cars but still we have some
points that are below this curve and it
means that if we apply the decision
based on this Freedman curve so maybe we
should give this woman oxytocin or even
cross-section but as we know with this
woman everything goes perfectly well so
they definitely don't need it nothing
okay and and here we have the same thing
just like min so of this statement okay
and final question is that we want to
boost just a little model that will tell
us okay how long should it take for this
woman to give birth is it okay or it's
maybe it's just it's not too long and we
have some factors and definitely the
most important one is if it's the first
time mother or second time mother
they're factors and here goes this
question of interpretability we want
something just simple okay and I made
some really simple decision tree okay
this is just an example but I showed
these two to midwives and actually what
they told me it's just okay you made the
tree great we like it we understand it
we want it we have something like that
in our books so this is probably the way
to go okay and here you have references
for for this first paper and some study
that cover similar topic okay
and why I'm talking about it because I
think there are still areas when you can
do something really simple but it's
actually important for our health
[Applause]